you know i generally will talk to and
challenge as an entrepreneur i'll do
some random types of interviews but
today i want to have a kneecap to
kneecap conversation with you about a
very important matter that
many people are affected by and here's
what it is
years ago i want to say in 2008 i sat
down with a very good friend of mine
and he said he was leading on empty at
the time
i said what do you mean you're leaning
on empty says pat i just i'm exhausted i
don't have any energy
and he and i were reading the same book
which is called leading on
empty by wayne cordero phenomenal book i
highly recommend it
and he got emotional and we were sitting
at the typical breakfast spot that we
would go to
and he was telling me what he was
dealing with with his church and what he
was doing with his family with his son
what all
all the stuff that we have in
conversations with it was a very very
emotional meeting right
i said interesting you know when people
are leading on empty
and years later fast forward to today
i'm 41 years old i've gone through a lot
of different stages what i'm
leading there's times that you don't
know what's going on you don't know
there's not a manual for something well
if there's ever been a time
where many people in many industries
today are leading on empty
it's today let me explain to you why
today
people are not just leading on empty
because of their finances
there are people that are leading on
empty today because of their marriage
they don't know what to do today with
their marriage because no one's ever
given a manual that said
here's how hard marriage is add kids add
in-laws at financial issues on top of
that add a pandemic
you're around no one's ever told us
these types of things people are leading
empty with finances
leading on empty with marriage leading
them empty with their kids leading on
empty with their parents
leading on empty with somebody in the
family that had coronavirus
maybe themselves maybe somebody they
loved maybe they lost somebody
maybe they're going through not being
able to handle everybody calling them
with all the fears and they don't know
what to tell them
but there's a lot of people today that
are leaning on empty so when you're
listening to this thing with pat
i'm kind of going through it right now
myself you know i don't know what to do
the other day my wife and i got into the
biggest fight ever
you know i don't know what to do my dad
keeps calling me so scared i don't know
what to do my grandma is worried on
what's going to be happening
i honestly don't know what to do i don't
have a
manual for this today or you lost your
job or somebody in your family lost
their job
you may be doing well you're making
money but maybe your sibling is not
because they're in a completely
different industry
people are leading on empty today
many of them are so what do you do about
it what can you do about it
if you and i are going through it a
couple things you may be watching the
same path
i'm good man everything's good in my
life great i'm glad you're there
but you may have other people in your
life that are not which means maybe it's
best to be a little bit more gentle
today
you may have somebody that lost their
income you don't know what it's like to
lose your income
you don't know what it is to lose your
150 000 or your income
to only be getting two three four
thousand dollars a month of benefits you
don't know what it's like to go through
that because you're not going through it
so you need to be a little bit more
gentle about it with them maybe you are
going through it yourself and you're
saying pat i don't know what the hell is
going on right now with my marriage i
think we're close
to finishing it up i don't know what's
going on right now my kids
i have no idea my kid's not even talking
to me right now maybe it's a good idea
when you go home tonight i say listen
hey john let me talk to you what's that
let's go to the room how you doing man
let's go for a walk
let's go for a walk how you feeling
what's on your mind what do you mean
what's this question about how you doing
what do you think about all this
chronovirus stuff
what do you think about all this school
shutting down when you talk to your
buddies what do you think about this
stuff dad i'm not going to lie to you
they're gonna have a breaking point they
need it they need a release
people need a little bit of a release i
was having a conversation earlier today
with one of our
co-workers and he just broke down crying
all of a sudden
he just needed a release i was having a
conversation yesterday with one of our
guys
that's how you doing just completely
just had to release out of nowhere
i talked to my kids my nanny i had a
long conversation with my mother the
other day she just needed somebody to
talk to
why because no one's ever been through
this before unless if you're 90 years
old
this is not common to too many people
many people are leading on empty in
different areas of their lives now
let me set this part aside i'm going to
give you the other side of the story as
well
some people are leaning on empty based
on
real issues right because some people
hear this message and they'll say things
like
oh that's why i'm not in a good place
and then you want to believe that you're
leading on empty
i'm actually in a very good place right
now myself i just know people around me
are
and and i don't want to lead on empty
because then i can't lead them so i need
to be energized so how did i do that to
myself because
i was leaning on empty in 2014 i was
leaning on empty in 2013
i made videos about it when i talked
about my anxiety attacks and panic
attacks
i was transparent about it i was going
through it and i was still working my
tail off and going through it you know
what i ended up realizing here's a few
things i ended up realizing that helped
me out
number one i cut out anything in my life
that wasn't a priority anything in my
life that wasn't a priority
anything stuff that was consuming my
mind that just didn't require my energy
i started cutting it out
you know it's funny i was reading a
strategy article earlier today
and it said one of the things about high
achievers those strategic thinkers that
people like to follow and work with
they're very selective what they give
their energy to it's as if
content that we produce over and over
and over again it doesn't matter how
many
high performing people you think about
it you read about
they eventually get to a point where
they say i'm not giving my energy to
everything
they become selective maybe you got to
be selective maybe you keep trying to
change people that you cannot change
i have a couple people in my life i've
tried so hard to try to change
you know encourage these guys to have
their lives get better
but no matter what happens it's the
world's fault it's their parents fault
it's their peers fault it's my fault
it's the economy's fault it's the
it's everything is everybody else's
fault so you may be watching and saying
well pat what do you do with people like
that
i can't solve everybody's problems all i
said to you is
the people that i love closely to me
that maybe are being quiet and not
saying anything right now
maybe it's worthy of a call these are
not people that are calling you bitching
at you
these are just people that are not
saying anything which is even scarier
because you don't know what they're
thinking about
just call them and say mom how you doing
that howard thinks
brother how you feeling man we haven't
spoken for a while baby how you doing
i don't know how you doing not like how
you doing how you doing
tell me how you feeling you know last
time my wife and i had a lengthy
conversation
hour and a half in the bed i said how
you doing what are you thinking
how we doing how's life where you're at
it's like well you know and all of a
sudden we had some serious conversations
together
just came out of nowhere but just a
simple question how you doing and it was
a conversation that needed to be had
imagine how many of those people in your
life that are going through it today
because you have to understand
sometimes when things are very very good
with you you think everybody else is
doing very good
they're not sometimes it's good to just
ask people around you that matter to you
the most
how are things on your end because you
never know if they're leading on empty
and if it's you you got to take a step
back and
start prioritizing things that you have
in your life that
are not that important you know if you
got your career that you're going you
got a big vision you want to do
something that's never been done before
and you kind of put on that kind of a
pressure because this is who you want to
be
well then you wanted this life you know
if
steve kerr's going through a lot of
pressure in playoffs and he's kind of
leading on empty he chose to be a head
coach of the golden state warriors
if elon musk decided to build spacex
because he wants to go travel to space
and
do something that's never been done
before and build civilization and mars
and claim these kinds of big things
he brought it on to himself sometimes
he's going to be by himself and sit
there and say what the hell am i saying
these big types of things
and even a guy like that is probably
going to have somebody around him saying
how you doing
how you feeling man i guarantee even a
guy like that has to go to somebody and
have that kind of a release in the
conversation
so again if you're going through it or
somebody you know is going through it
it's part of life okay the season's
gonna go by i can't say this enough
times
it is not gonna be like this forever
within a year two years three years five
years
we're gonna look back at this and we're
gonna learn from this and things are
going to be better but sometimes in the
interim when it's happening
you think it's the end of the world so
if everything's good with you
drop a jingle to five people today and
lift them up okay
people that haven't reached out to you
people that haven't spoken to you for a
while
people that haven't done anything with
you that you know they're not in the
best of situations right now because
their industry is not doing well
make that phone call and if you yourself
are maybe not in the best state where
you're at yourself
maybe go pick up some right books to
read i got a video for you to watch one
of them i did title 10
uh a ways to deal with crisis if you've
never watched it's a very good video
because this is how i handle crisis
because
i'm in a situation where i'm dealing
with a lot of things a lot of times with
wife kids startup this business that
business investments lawyers
carriers lawsuits all the stuff that
you're dealing with and sometimes it can
be overwhelming
just know that you're not a robot you're
not a machine we had a crisis that
happened last week a massive one
and a guy said how come that doesn't
bother i said because i have no control
over it i don't i don't worry about
stuff that i have no control over
i only put my energy into things i have
control over
and if you do if you do some of those
things and you simply go to a space of
knowing that
good things are around the corner
sometimes that simple thought
will give you the strength to carry on
and do your best and this time because
you know great times around the corner
so i don't want to talk about business
today i just want to talk to you today
that's all it is i just want to say how
you doing that's all i was concerned
about
nothing else nothing but this is not
about being a millionaire it's not about
being a great founder not about being a
great entrepreneur it's just about being
a
human being understanding you're not a
machine you're not a robot you have
feelings
you have emotions times are going to be
weird at times and it's okay
it's okay the standard in life was never
perfection
the standard in life was progress and
improvement that's all it is
you ain't supposed to be perfect buddy
i'm telling you you're just supposed to
improve
and you do that eventually everything
will work itself out
so having said that have a great week
this week
everything's gonna work out keep your
chin up keep your head up
and if you're having somebody in your
life that is leaning on empty drop them
a jingle have a great week today